time for the Continental Tire coaches
corner from sunday ranges snow and
everything in between Continental Tire
is engineered to tire for what you do
extraordinary performance and
reliability putting confidence into
driving for more for more information
and the location of a dealer near you
visit Continental Tire Calm Continental
Tire for what you do the hall of famer
Hornets associate head coach Patrick
Ewing back on the program how are you
Patrick I can't complain Dan you know my
passion bucket take us back to 1985 with
the draft what do you remember and what
did you do after you were drafted to
celebrate being the number one pick you
know I just remembered you know first of
all remember the lottery the lottery was
a big part of it you know after the
larger end was gonna be the first player
picked and was going to New York
you know come flying up to New York
saying I'm I don't even remember which
hotel we stayed at but staying in the
hotel and coming over early and going
over all the proceedings and you know
finally having my name called and
walking up on the stage and you know
shaking the commissioner's hand and
holding the jersey up with to the
butcher and then everything was a blur
from there you know just all the media
requests you know coming to the back all
the media requests all the interviews
and all the things that we had to go
through but I mean it's it was a it was
a special night you know everybody or
every player who our people play the
game dream about that night finally
having your name calling and you know
being one of the players to be drafted
so it was a it was a great night what
about the the lottery itself when you
hear read that it was rigged so the
Knicks would be able to pick you what
was your reaction
but you know it's funny because even I
hear it even today every time the
lottery comes on there's always somebody
that talked about it you know what
anything is possible but I don't see
that happening you know in New York was
definitely one of the places I wanted to
go to it wasn't my first choice at first
I wanted to go to Golden State to play
with Oh Carly teammate Erik sleepy Floyd
one stay lost and definite New York was
my was my my choice it was close to
Boston it was close to New York DC had a
lot of friends in the area so if it was
rigged it was rigged for the right
reasons you know New York meet there
needs to be a strong team in the mecca
and you know me being drafted by the
next help help for that he'll help that
happen what do you think of what the
next did with Derrick Rose picking him
up bringing in Jeff hornacek maybe
moving a little further away from the
triangle offense
um you know honestly he's a very good
coach had opportunity to play against
him we coached against him he's a fine
coach he's he's done he's gonna do fine
be fine there Rose is a little bit of a
risk to see you know that is which Rose
are you gonna get is he gonna be healthy
is it gonna be the MVP that he get back
to his empty MVP level or is he gonna be
you know banged up in and out of the
lineup if he can come back and and be
the Derrick Rose of all is definitely
gonna help him I think you know it's a
no-brainer what they gave up for him it
was something good and you know like we
have to see how he and he and Melo are
able to co-exist together
he's Patrick Ewing he's the Hornets
associate head coach what's the best and
worst thing about being on the coaching
staff with Michael Jordan as your boss
after listen to all the crap you know
even yeah he is a man even now he has
never changed after since we've been 18
he's always he's been the same
person always you know talking trash
picking at you you've never beat me all
the stuff that he you know all the
things that he the trash that he talks
on it when we're all together the same
thing is never changed but do you know
also that the best day the great great
thing about working for him is that he's
played the game he understand a lot of
the things that you know we as coaches
have to go through and he's very you
know he's I'm not gonna say easy on us
but he understands and he's able to give
us a little bit away when Li Wei needed
is LeBron entering Michael Jordan
territory
LeBron gonna Bron James is a great
player he's a great player in this era
but he's not Michael Jordan you know
it's two different animal Michael was
was a killer he's an assassin
you know LeBron is more of us of a
facilitator he's you know he's of the
guy that she's gonna give the ball and
he's gonna he's probably he's thinking
shoot first before passed where Michael
you give him the ball he's thinking he's
gonna score fifty on you and then he's
gonna pass you know you know and Michael
Joe was the best player the greatest
player in my era there's been a lot of
great players in this league and it's
hard to you know but to give one player
that best ever crown but all I can say
is in my era Michael Jordan was the best
player in my era and he's I mean I
haven't seen anybody else if Kobe is I
guess the closest came the closest to
him but LeBron is great but he's not
Michael Jordan who would you want is
your teammate Jordan or LeBron so you
know I'm throwing you the ball abroad
LeBron is definitely go go go faster a
lot more than Michael but you know when
when at the bottom line is you every as
players we want to win and you know when
I went out when you when you when you
have somebody you know we were always
equate basketball to war we always talk
about the Fox so even though it's nut is
there's nothing like war but you know
when you when you when you have somebody
in your foxhole you want to know if
they're gonna have your back and not to
say that LeBron would not gonna have it
won't have your back but I know what
Michaels brings to the table and I would
definitely uh would rather that Rhett
would rather hear did you ever try to
get Jordan to come to the Knicks you
know that wasn't gonna happen no I've
never we know that's the thing you know
a lot of people talked about when LeBron
went to play in Miami you know about us
you know
why didn't we do things do things like
that but you know we we always wanted to
beat each other you know we always want
to dominate one another so that the fact
that to talk about teaming up never
never came into our minds if you played
if you were in college now how important
or how different would your game be or
being developed to go into the NBA would
you be different than what you were when
you played at Georgetown I don't think
I'll be any different you know I
probably shooted a lot more than I did
in college you know back when I played
it was more they you they they taught
you to play inside-out where this in
this era most of the players are all
perimeter players everybody's on the
perimeter
so in that respect it might have changed
a little bit might of my arm I scored a
lot more but in in terms of all the
other things that I brought to the table
I think that wouldn't it wouldn't change
I still there still is a man for a shot
blocker person to protect the rim and I
did that they still demand for for a
dominant rebounder and I was a dominant
rebounder so all the other things are
that's a part of my game it's still you
know there's still a need for it the
only difference is a lot now a lot more
lot more of the bigs or more perimeter
oriented then back when I play you know
how many threes you had in your career I
think I probably had about five I got
you at 19 threes
that's not bad
not bad but I knew I knew where my bed
with my friend you know it's funny
because I tell you know I tell people at
this story about when I was in college
we played we played the Virginia I was a
sophomore we played Virginia and Ralph
Sampson came down and he took took up a
problem with the college three back then
it would have been in college three and
I come that came down the other to the
other end and I took a chat about the
top of the key
coach Thompson called timeout and cursed
me out is his son what blank are you
doing I don't care if he shoes out there
you are saying you're at black and
opposed and work on your postgame I saw
this quote speaking of Coach he talked
about you he says he's a smart player
great leader but you very seldom hear
intelligence associated with height in
the NBA or in college therefore they
think the people who are thinking on the
floor all-time are all the time regards
Patrick is suffering from that it is
that how much of that is hurting you why
not talk to you about this being a head
coach and I hope you get that
opportunity but being a big man does
that hurt you and being recognized as
somebody who can be a head coach oh
definitely I think it definitely does
hurt but you know but basketball is not
rocket scientist you know we all in in
they talk about when people think about
Mars they always think about the
Poincare position where they never
really equate the center position which
Mars but the same thing that the guards
are doing we're doing the same thing on
the other end they are they're the floor
leaders on the offensive end where the
floor leaders on the defensive end and
even when I played I was a floor either
on the offensive and also because a lot
of times you know I would still be
calling the plays I was telling the
guards what place to run so you know it
is what it is
you know I've got I was able to get two
interviews this year and I did extremely
well with them I didn't get the job but
I'm getting closer and you know
hopefully one day soon
you know you I come on there and we'll
be talking about the fact that I've got
an opportunity and and how good I'm
gonna do it and then I can rip you when
you don't do well that's what that's one
thing I've learned if you if you don't
have thick skin no matter what you do
you want your in and especially
especially as a coach because there's
always there's always gonna be a Monday
morning Monday Morning Quarterback if
you don't have thick skin you won't last
yeah but what you went through is a
player I mean you you have to have thick
skin just to survive so that that'll be
the least of your worries when you
become a head coach a bigger trash
talker bird or Jordan I'm gonna put them
right up there equal really equal but
birds say stuff to you Oh woody come on
now you know uh Larry the legend this
man he talked more trash you know
they're equal but Larry has been is
Michael's been talking trash is the
first day I met him with at seventeen
eighteen Larry's been talking trash ever
since I stepped on the court he's always
talking about how you know I'll grade it
out great his Boston Celtics team is I
remember exhibit McDonald tells a story
about he was playing in Seattle and um
he ever tried to score Blair came down
the court and insects I'm running right
here I'm going to run to write this spot
right here this is he told him to plate
he said I'm running right here to this
spot and there's nothing you can do
about it he said Larry ran to this spot
turn around shot the ball walked off the
court of all his nothing but the bottom
of the net oh they all told they're
great Larry is a great great player
magic Michael is a great great player
and they talk so much trash but the
difference is they can back it up hey
Patrick always great talk to you and
have fun and once again well keep an eye
on that opportunity for you to become a
head head coach in the NBA thanks for
joining us is all
and thanks for having me on dan I
appreciate it night that's Patrick Ewing
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience